♪♪♪♪♪
>> LAST TIME ON "TOP MODEL"...
>> THERE WAS NO STOPPING ME
'CAUSE I LOVE RUNWAY, PERIOD.
>> AND THE WINNER--DALYA.
>> YES!
>> YAY! THAT'S AWESOME!
>> ACTION.
>> HOW THE HECK
DO YOU MAKE COFFEE SEXY?
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> VERY GOOD, UH, KASIA.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE GOT
A SHOT OF US POURING THE COFFEE.
>> ALEXANDRIA--SHE WAS BUSY
DOING FRANCESCO'S JOB.
>> DON'T LOOK BACK OVER HERE
'CAUSE I'M NOT THERE ANYMORE.
>> MMM. DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> SARA, IT'S ABOUT AS SEXY
AS WATCHING PAINT DRY.
>> CONFIDENCE WINS, ALEXANDRIA.
AND SARA WAS SENT HOME.
NINE GIRLS ARE LEFT,
BUT ONLY ONE WILL HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH IMG, COVERGIRL,
AND APPEAR ON THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO DO YOU THINK
WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HOME SWEET HOME.
>> SWEET HOME.
>> KASIA!
>> WHOA!
>> "CRAZY GOOD"
AND "EXTRAORDINARY."
>> FINALLY I GOT CALLED FIRST.
I'M SO HAPPY.
I FEEL LIKE I DESERVE IT
'CAUSE I MILKED EVERY SECOND
OF THAT COMMERCIAL
AND THAT'S, LIKE,
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO.
>> IT'S BEAUTIFUL. I LOVE IT.
KASIA DID AMAZING,
BUT THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
THAT I'M MORE THAN CAPABLE
OF BEING ONE OF
THE STRONGEST COMPETITORS HERE.
>> I'M JUST GLAD--I'M JUST...
>> YOU KNOCKED IT
OUT OF THE PARK.
>> GLAD IT PAID OFF, YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH.
I'VE BEEN MODELING
SINCE 16 YEARS OLD,
AND I'VE ALREADY EXPERIENCED
L.A. FASHION WEEK,
SO I DO THINK
I HAVE AN UPPER HAND,
BUT I DON'T THINK
SOME OF THE GIRLS IN THE HOUSE
KNOW HOW AMAZING THIS IS.
TO BE A COVERGIRL--
DO YOU KNOW HOW BIG THAT IS?
>> IT HURTS ME THAT I KNOW
THAT I DID MY BEST,
AND THEN WE GET IN THERE,
AND THEY'RE LIKE, "OH, SORRY.
YOU KIND OF (bleep) SUCK."
>> I LIKE HOW HE SAID
THAT I WAS TRYING TO DIRECT,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"NO! NO, NO, NO, NO, NO."
>> YOU WEREN'T DIRECTING.
>> WHOA. ROLL BACK.
SO LAST PANEL,
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
BECAUSE MR. JAY HAD SAID
THAT I WAS TRYING
TO DIRECT PEOPLE AGAIN.
>> IT'LL BE THE LAST TIME
THAT I TELL YOU THAT
YOU COULD POSSIBLY BE GOING HOME
BECAUSE OF ATTITUDE.
>> IT WON'T EVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT'S A REALLY HEAVY, LIKE,
BURDEN ON MY CHEST
BECAUSE I'M THIS POSITIVE,
ARTISTIC CALIFORNIA GIRL,
AND NOW PEOPLE ARE
SEEING ME IN A DIFFERENT LIGHT,
AND I REALLY
JUST DON'T LIKE THAT--
WHEN PEOPLE DON'T GET ME.
>> OH, TYRA MAIL, LADIES.
>> WHO LIKES BUSH?
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> SAY IT LIKE YOU MEAN IT.
>> "EVERY GOOD LESSON
STARTS WITH A GOOD FOUNDATION."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> THAT'S A CHALLENGE,
IF I EVER HEARD ONE.
>> I HATE WEAVES.
I'M NOT THINKING ABOUT
ANYTHING ELSE
BUT GETTING THIS WEAVE
OFF MY HEAD.
THEY TOOK IT OUT
AND THEY GAVE ME, YOU KNOW,
A DAY OR TWO TO HEAL,
THEN THEY PUT IT BACK IN.
BUT NOW I HAVE A RASH
ALL OVER MY SCALP.
OW!
I'M PISSED ALL DAY LONG.
CONSTANT ITCHY PAIN.
I WOULD NEVER PAY
FOR THE (bleep)
ON MY (bleep) HEAD.
>> OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S MY TOWEL.
THERE WAS A TOWEL RIGHT HERE.
WHO PICKED IT UP?
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE'S SUCH A PSYCHO.
SHE SNAPS AT ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> I'M SORRY.
I'M NOT YELLING, AND I DON'T
REALLY GIVE A (bleep).
I HAVEN'T--I HAVEN'T SAID
MORE THAN TWO WORDS
TO (bleep) ANYONE
SINCE WE'VE GOTTEN HOME.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
YOU JUST SAID, LIKE,
A WHOLE... MONOLOGUE.
>> GREAT VOCABULARY.
>> WELL, THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> WASN'T THERE
AN ENTIRE CONVERSATION
AT PANEL TONIGHT--
"STOP BEING A DIVA, STOP ACTING
LIKE YOU OWN EVERYTHING"?
AND THEN SHE COMES HOME
AND STARTS FIGHTING. (laughs)
>> ABOUT A TOWEL.
I GUARANTEE EVERYONE GOES
IN THEIR CONFESSIONAL
AND BITCHES ABOUT ALEXANDRIA,
BECAUSE SHE'S GETTING
ON EVERYONE'S NERVES.
>> SHE'S, LIKE,
OBNOXIOUS, CONTROLLING.
>> I FEEL LIKE
MAYBE SHE'S BIPOLAR.
>> SEVERE PSYCHOLOGICAL ISSUES.
>> I'M KINDA SCARED OF HER.
>> ETCETERA, ETCETERA, ETCETERA.
>> BUT HER ATTITUDE'S
GONNA DEFEAT HER.
>> LET THE SHIP SINK.
(laughter)
>> (laughs)
>> WELL, HEY, GOOD MORNING.
>> HELLO.
>> WELL, I'M SURE, BY NOW,
YOU GUYS OBVIOUSLY KNOW
THAT ONE OF YOU IS GOING TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> WHICH MEANS ONE OF YOU IS
GONNA GET THAT $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL.
THAT REALLY SOLIDIFIES
YOUR STATUS AS A TOP MODEL,
AND THAT IS
HUGE.
>> I THINK I'LL DIE
IF I GET A COVERGIRL CONTRACT.
IT'S SUCH AN AMAZING BRAND
TO REPRESENT.
LIKE, EVERY GIRL WANTS
TO BE A COVERGIRL.
>> SO FOR TODAY'S CHALLENGE,
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO IS
A "GET THE LOOK" ONLINE VIDEO
TO HELP COVERGIRLS EVERYWHERE
KIND OF TAKE THEIR LOOK
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
NOW YOU'VE ALL HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
THE FABULOUS
CELEBRITY MAKEUP ARTIST
MR. VINCENT.
>> HEY, GIRLS.
TODAY YOU'RE GONNA BE SPLIT
INTO THREE TEAMS OF THREE.
EACH TEAM IS GONNA BE ASSIGNED
ONE KIND OF LOOK,
AND YOU'LL GET A WHOLE RANGE
OF COVERGIRL PRODUCTS
TO EMPHASIZE YOUR LOOK,
BUT I WANT YOU TO HIGHLIGHT
COVERGIRL'S
NatureLuxe SILK FOUNDATION.
(ding)
>> YOU'LL HAVE ONE HOUR
TO CONSULT WITH ME
AND WORK WITH EACH OTHER
TO COME UP WITH
YOUR BEST 1-MINUTE PRESENTATION.
>> NOW AFTER THAT,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TEN MINUTES
TO GET YOUR BEST TAKE,
AND I'M GOING TO PICK
THE WINNING TEAM
BASED ON WHO IS GONNA GIVE ME
THE MOST INTERESTING
AND INFORMATIVE PRESENTATION.
I WANT YOU GUYS TO REALIZE
THIS IS A BIG DEAL
BECAUSE THAT VIDEO WILL BE
POSTED ON covergirl.com
FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD TO SEE.
SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS
WE GOT ALL THESE CARDS
HERE IN THIS BOWL.
>> WE'RE ALL TOLD
THAT WE GET TO CHOOSE OUR FATES.
IT'S GONNA BE TALENT,
DIRECTOR, AND WRITER.
I GO TO REACH TO GRAB MINE,
AND IT SAYS "TALENT."
YES! LIKE, I DON'T HAVE TO
BE THE DIRECTOR.
I DON'T HAVE TO BE THE WRITER.
>> YAY!
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> OUR GROUP!
MY TEAMMATES ARE MY ROOMMATES,
MONIQUE AND MOLLY.
GREAT. SO I CAN'T GO WRONG.
>> YOUR HOUR IS GONNA START
RIGHT NOW,
AND YOU'VE GOT YOUR STATIONS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OOH.
>> ALEXANDRIA'S THE TALENT,
I'M THE DIRECTOR,
AND MOLLY'S THE WRITER.
DAY CASUAL.
>> SWEET.
>> OKAY, SWEET.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I HAVEN'T GOT BEST PICTURE
ONE TIME OR WON A CHALLENGE.
IT'S TIME TO WIN SOMETHING.
YEAH, LET'S FOCUS ON HER LIPS.
>> I NEED TO KNOW MY PRODUCTS
'CAUSE I AM THE TALENT.
>> OH, GREAT.
LIKE, THIS IS GONNA BE
A PAIN IN THE ASS.
>> GLOSS BALM--
I REALLY LIKE THIS.
>> ALEXANDRIA--SHE ALWAYS
COMES OFF REALLY BITCHY,
AND I DON'T THINK
SHE REALIZES IT.
>> WHAT WOULD I DO NORMALLY?
I WOULD--
I GOT OUT OF THE OCEAN.
WE STARTED GOING OVER
THE LINES AND STUFF,
AND I WANTED TO THROW IN
SOMETHING ABOUT ME SURFING.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT GONNA BE BOSSY
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
>> "I NEVER LEAVE HOME
WITHOUT MY"--
>> "I NEVER LEAVE HOME WITHOUT
MY NatureLuxe GLOSS BALM.
IT HAS COLOR SHEEN
AND S.P.F. TO PROTECT YOUR LIPS,
AND ALWAYS GIVES MY OUTFIT,
LIKE, AN EXTRA POP."
>> WHY DON'T YOU JUST SAY,
"I DASH ON
A SHEER, NATURAL-LOOKING BLUSH.
I FEATHER MY EYES WITH THE..."
>> WELL, THEN DO IT.
IF YOU'RE GONNA--
TRYING TO WRITE THE WHOLE THING,
JUST DO IT.
>> NO, I'M NOT TRYING TO--
I'M NOT WRITING IT.
I'M NOT THE WRITER.
(two gunshots)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OKAY,
THE LIP PERFECTION LIPSTICK
ACCENTS...
>> IT ACCENTS
THE SILKY FOUNDATION.
>> OR IT GIVES A POP.
>> AND WITH 44 SHADES
TO CHOOSE FROM...
>> WAIT, WAIT.
>> EVERY GIRL CAN FIND
THEIR COLOR.
THE COVERGIRL LOOK THAT WE HAVE
IS THE RED CARPET/EVENING TYPE
OF A LOOK.
OUR TEAM DEFINITELY IS WORKING
REALLY, REALLY WELL TOGETHER.
IN THE END,
IT NEEDS TO BE COMFORTABLE,
IT NEEDS TO BE...
(speaks indistinctly)
>> RIGHT.
>> DALYA, UM, WANTS TO GO
TO, LIKE, A PARTY OR SOMETHING.
WHAT COVERGIRL IS
GONNA HELP HER DO IS
GET NOTICED, BUT IN A GOOD WAY.
>> OUR WHOLE STORY WAS THERE IS
THIS ONE PARTICULAR DUDE
THAT I WANNA IMPRESS,
AND I GOTTA IMPRESS HIM
WITH MY EYES.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> LIKE, WE'RE DOING
THE BOLD/COLORFUL EYE.
WHICH PRODUCTS
DOES SHE NEED TO USE FOR THAT?
>> FOR BOLD EYES, I WOULD SAY
THE SmokyShadowBlast IS
PRETTY MUCH
THE WAY YOU WANNA GO.
AND DON'T BE AFRAID
TO PLAY WITH YOUR MAKEUP.
>> THE THREE OF US FELT LIKE
OUR GROUP WAS THE STRONGEST,
AND WE WERE REALLY CONFIDENT.
BUT LAST WEEK, WITH
THE FIERCE ROAST COMMERCIAL,
DALYA HAD TROUBLE EMOTING.
>> MMM.
DOESN'T FIERCE ROAST
SMELL DELICIOUS?
>> IT'S A LITTLE PAINFUL.
>> UGH.
>> IT'S LIGHTWEIGHT,
FLAWLESS COVERAGE.
LIGHTWEIGHT.
SO IT WAS OUR DECISION
TO MAKE IT CONVERSATIONAL.
WE DIDN'T HAVE, LIKE,
A WRITTEN SCRIPT, REALLY.
WE JUST HAD KEY POINTS
THAT SHE NEEDED TO MENTION,
AND I FELT LIKE
THIS IS GONNA BE FABULOUS.
>> NatureLuxe--
THIS FEELS EFFORTLESS.
THIS FEELS...
(sighs)
>> I KNOW YOU'RE DOING YOUR JOB.
I DON'T WANT TO INTERRUPT,
BUT WE GOT ABOUT 15 MINUTES.
OKAY?
>> THANK YOU.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO FEEL
UNCONFIDENT.
>> CAN YOU JUST
LET ME PRACTICE, PLEASE?
>> WELL...
EVERY TIME I'D TRY
TO DIRECT HER, SHE'D SAY,
"CAN I JUST LEARN MY LINES?"
>> WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE A TEAM.
>> YEAH, BUT YOU'RE NOT
LETTING US BE A TEAM, DUDE.
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO LEARN
MY LINES, AND YOU GUYS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING, TOO.
JUST STAND UP AND HELP ME.
>> YEAH, AND THEN WHEN WE ASK
YOU SOMETHING OR TRY TO...
>> WE TRY TO HELP YOU
ALL THE TIME.
>> OR TRY TO TALK ABOUT IT,
YOU'RE LIKE, "SHUT UP."
>> WELL, I FEEL LIKE
THE DIRECTOR SHOULD BE
DOING YOUR JOB, AND YOU SHOULD
BE WRITING THE LINES AND NOT--
>> SO NOW YOU'RE TELLING ME
THAT I'M NOT DOING MY JOB?
>> MONIQUE, ALEXANDRIA,
AND MOLLY--THEY'RE ARE
FIGHTIN' LIKE DOGS AND CATS.
I MEAN, I'M SO GLAD
I WAS NOT ON THAT TEAM.
>> I JUST DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
AT ALL NOW.
IT WAS A LITTLE FRUSTRATING,
AND THEN ESPECIALLY WITH
THE WORDS THAT THEY SAID--
"RUDE" AND "ATTITUDE"
AND STUFF LIKE THAT,
AFTER PANEL JUST SAYING
THE SAME TO ME.
NOW I REALLY DON'T FEEL
LIKE DOING THIS.
I FEEL LIKE (bleep).
>> THIS BITCH--
I CAN'T STAND HER
BECAUSE I REALLY WANNA WIN.
SHE'S GONNA LOOK LIKE AN IDIOT.
IT'S GONNA BE A HUGE MESS.
>> I JUST DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
AT ALL NOW.
I'M SITTING THERE, AND I HAVE,
LIKE, TEN MINUTES LEFT
TO MEMORIZE MY LINES,
AND MY TEAMMATES ARE TELLING ME
THAT I HAVE A BAD ATTITUDE.
NOW I REALLY DON'T FEEL
LIKE DOING THIS.
>> WE DON'T REALLY NEED
TO TALK ABOUT THE FRUSTRATION
AND PROBLEMS RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE COMMERCIAL.
>> BUT I'M THE TALENT.
>> YOU'RE JUST BEING BITCHY.
WHILE SHE'S GETTING LIKE THIS,
LIKE, I'M TRYING TO, LIKE,
EASE THE TENSION.
DO YOU WANT A HUG?
SHOULD WE ALL HUG OR SOMETHING?
DO A THREE-WAY KISS?
LIKE, WHAT'S--WHAT'S GONNA
MAKE YOU FEEL HAPPIER?
>> HAVE AN ORGY.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST KNOW I LOOK LIKE
A (bleep).
>> I'M TRYING
TO KEEP THINGS CALM
BECAUSE IF ALEXANDRIA'S
ALL FRAZZLED LIKE THAT
AND "ABOUT TO CRY"
WHEN WE'RE IN FRONT OF JAY,
SHE'S GONNA FORGET EVERYTHING.
>> SO, GROUP 1,
>> PERFECT. YES, THAT'S US.
>> YOU GUYS ARE READY TO GO?
>> YES!
>> WE'RE ABSOLUTELY READY TO GO.
I ONLY HAVE TEN MINUTES TO GET
ONE FLAWLESS, CONTINUOUS TAKE
OF MIKAELA RUNNING THROUGH
OUR LITTLE OUTLINE.
AND SO THE PRESSURE
WAS REALLY ON.
OKAY, MIKAELA, ARE YOU READY?
ARE YOU--
>> YES.
>> ALL RIGHTY. ACTION!
>> GETTING READY
FOR A BIG NIGHT OUT IS
HALF THE FUN,
AND EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT MAKEUP IS THEBEST PART.
EVERY COVERGIRL KNOWS
THAT A PERFECT FOUNDATION--
UGH! (bleep)
>> START FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> OKAY.
>> THERE'S NO EDITING.
>> OH, (bleep). OKAY.
>> OKAY, ACTION.
>> GOOD?
>> MIKAELA JUST LOOKS
SO BEAUTIFUL.
SHE'S RADIANT, SHE'S SMILING,
BUT MIKAELA IS, YOU KNOW,
USING THE F-WORD
A LITTLE TOO MUCH FOR MY LIKING.
>> UGH! (bleep).
>> (imitates buzzer) CUT.
>> SORRY, GUYS.
>> MIKAELA, IT'S FINE.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
DON'T PANIC.
>> 'CAUSE YOU REALIZE THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE A TAKE
THAT YOU CAN USE.
>> YEAH. AND ACTION.
IT WAS DEFINITELY HARD.
IT'S--I MEAN,
I'VE NEVER DIRECTED BEFORE,
AND THEN YOU GET DOWN
TO ONE MINUTE,
AND YOU STILL NEED A GOOD CUT.
>> AND NEXT, BY ADDING
COVERGIRL SIMPLY AGELESS BLUSH,
IT GIVES ME
A REALLY GREAT COMPLEMENT
TO THAT FRESH COMPLEXION
THAT THE FOUNDATION GAVE ME.
>> GROUP 1--THEY HAD, LIKE,
A VERY DISTINCT SCRIPT.
WE WERE LIKE, OH, NO, NO, NO.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY WANT MORE
OF A CONVERSATION.
>> LAST BUT NOT LEAST--
THE LIP PERFECTION LIPSTICK.
REALLY ADDS A BOLD POP OF COLOR.
WITH OVER 44 SHADES,
EVERY COVERGIRL CAN FIND
HER SIGNATURE LIPSTICK
AND THEN SOME.
WITH COVERGIRL,
I CAN ROCK MY LOOK MY WAY.
>> CUT.
YAY! WE DID IT. AWESOME.
>> AND YOU GOT ALL THE LINES IN.
>> TEN MINUTES STARTS NOW.
>> DO I JUST SAY "ACTION"
WHENEVER?
AND ACTION.
>> WHEN YOU'RE READY.
>> HI.
>> SO I'M GOING
TO THIS PARTY TONIGHT,
AND I NEED TO STAND OUT
IN THE CROWD.
I NEED SOMETHING LIGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> NatureLuxe FOUNDATION--
IT ALMOST FEELS SMOOTH...
>> OKAY, CUT. CUT. START OVER.
WAIT UNTIL
HE PUTS IT ON INSTEAD.
>> OKAY.
>> HI.
>> HEY. SO I'M GOING
TO THIS PARTY TONIGHT,
AND I NEED TO STAND OUT
IN THE CROWD.
I NEED SOMETHING
THAT'S ALMOST LIGHTWEIGHT,
A FOUNDATION.
WOW. NatureLuxe.
>> (whispers) WHAT'S THE NAME
OF THE PRODUCT?
>> NatureLuxe,
UH, SILK FOUNDATION.
>> SHE'S NOT SAYING "SILK."
>> SORRY.
>> WE NEED--YOU NEED TO SAY
"THE NatureLuxe
SILK FOUNDATION."
YOU NEED TO SAY THE WHOLE NAME
OF, YOU KNOW, THE PRODUCT.
>> NYET.
ALL I HAD TO DO WAS REMEMBER
WHAT HANNAH TOLD ME TO SAY,
BUT I FEEL LIKE I'M SINKING.
>> AND ACTION.
>> IS THIS
THE NatureLuxe SILK FOUNDATION?
>> YES.
>> WOW. AS YOU'RE ADDING THIS
TO MY SKIN,
IT FEELS LIKE A SMOOTH COVERAGE,
AND I ALMOST FEEL KINDA NAKED.
>> HANNAH, JACLYN, AND DALYA--
THEY SEEMED
A LITTLE BIT DISORGANIZED.
>> LIKE I'M ALMOST NAKED ALMOST.
>> CUT. OKAY.
SORRY. FROM THE TOP.
>> ALL OF US OTHER GIRLS SEE
THAT IT'S KIND OF A TRAIN WRECK.
>> BUT, YOU KNOW,
I'M LOOKING FOR SOME COLOR.
>> HOW ABOUT SmokyShadowBlast?
>> SmokyShadowBlast.
ALL RIGHT.
>> DALYA IS
A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE,
AND THERE'S NOTHING
ABOUT THIS LITTLE VIDEO
THAT'S INTERESTING
AT THIS POINT.
>> WOW. LIQUILINE BLAST.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> I LOVE THE FACT
THAT IT'S JUST--IT'S SMOOTH,
LIKE LIQUID LINER,
BUT IT'S A--IT'S A PENCIL.
IT'S A STICK.
(buzzer sounds)
>> SO YOU'RE OUT OF TIME
RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE TO CUT YOU
BEFORE YOU CAN CUT HER.
>> I WAS LIKE, AW, THAT HURTS.
I'M NOT LIVING UP TO PAR
TO WHAT I CAN NORMALLY DO.
>> OKAY,
YOU'RE A CALIFORNIA SURFER,
AWESOME, ROCK, RAD CHICK,
TOTALLY AWESOME.
>> READY?
>> AND ACTION.
>> I LOVE STARTING OUT--
WAIT. (groans)
>> "WITH THIS NATURAL DAYTIME"--
>> I KNOW.
>> OKAY. OKAY, AND ACTION.
>> ACTION.
WITH THIS NATURAL,
DAYTIME LOOK...
>> I KEPT HEARING ALEXANDRIA
SAYING, LIKE, "ACTION,"
AND I'M JUST LIKE, REALLY?
YOU'VE BEEN TOLD TWICE NOW
TO STOP BEING THE BOSS.
>> I GET SUCH A FLAWLESS FINISH
AND A DA--
I'M GONNA HAVE TO START OVER.
SORRY.
>> OKAY.
>> JUST RELAX.
>> MM. I NEED TO CALM DOWN.
>> IT'S OKAY, BABY.
TOTALLY GOT IT.
YOU'RE DOING AWESOME.
AND ACTION.
>> MONIQUE--SHE'S CALM,
SHE'S SMOOTH, SHE'S COLLECTED,
AND THAT'S THE ENERGY
THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH DIFFICULT TALENT.
>> WITH THE NatureLuxe...
>> CUT. SILK FOUNDATION.
>> AGAIN.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> YES, IT DOES.
>> IT'S--YOU'RE FINE.
SHE'S GETTING ALL FRUSTRATED,
AND I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE.
BUT EVEN WHEN YOU'RE
FRUSTRATED LIKE THAT,
JUST KEEP IT TOGETHER
SO THAT WE STILL HAVE A CHANCE
OF WINNING THIS CHALLENGE.
>> NEXT, I MOVE ON WITH
HIGHLIGHTING MY CHEEKS WITH
THE TRUblend MINERAL BLUSH.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
I CAN NEVER LEAVE HOME WITHOUT
MY NatureLuxe GLOSS BALM.
IT HAS COLOR, SHEEN,
AND S.P.F. 15--
PERFECT BECAUSE
I'M ALWAYS IN THE SUN.
>> CUT.
YAY! GOOD JOB. THAT WAS GOOD.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE 15 SECONDS.
WHAT DO YOU WANNA DO WITH THAT?
>> OKAY. WE'RE DONE.
>> THANK YOU, REALLY.
>> NO WORRIES. (chuckles)
>> OH, HEY, WHO KILLED IT?
ME, ME, ME. (laughs)
>> SO, GROUP 1,
I'LL JUST START WITH YOU.
NOW, MIKAELA,
NEVER HEARD A COVERGIRL
USE THE F-WORD THAT MANY TIMES.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> BUT YOU FOUND A WAY
TO SCHLEP IT OFF.
YOU REMEMBERED THAT IT WAS ABOUT
TALKING TO SOMEBODY AT HOME,
AND IT WAS THAT RELATABILITY
THAT DREW ME IN
TO YOUR PERFORMANCE.
SO, GROUP 2,
MAKING THINGS CONVERSATIONAL,
UM, DEFINITELY TAKES IT
OUT OF THE COMMERCIAL REALM
'CAUSE THIS WAS NOT
A TV COMMERCIAL.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I DIDN'T FEEL THAT IT WAS
SUPER INFORMATIVE.
>> (mouths words)
>> SO WITH GROUP 3,
ALEXANDRIA, EVERY NOW AND THEN,
YOU SAY, "OKAY, WE'RE--
WE'RE STOPPING. OKAY, ACTION."
THAT'S HERJOB.
>> I WAS SAYING TO MYSELF,
"ACTION."
>> BUT, MONIQUE, YOU WERE
VERY CALM, COOL, AND COLLECTED.
YOU KEPT ALEXANDRIA GOING,
AND YOU GOT TO THAT ONE TAKE,
AND IT WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
SO NOW FOR THE WINNING TEAM.
THIS WAS PRETTY TOUGH
BECAUSE WE HAD TO FIND A TAKE
THAT DEFINITELY REPRESENTS
THE COVERGIRL BRAND
AND CAN REPRESENT
ON A WORLDWIDE LEVEL.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE TEAM 1
AND BRITTANI WORKED THAT OUT.
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> IT'S KIND OF UNREAL
THAT THEY'RE GONNA, LIKE,
PUT ME ON covergirl.com
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
OUR OWN LITTLE WEBISODE.
IT'S--IT'S REALLY AMAZING.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU GUYS WORKED TOGETHER
AS A TEAM.
>> ONCE AGAIN, I'M ON THE TEAM
THAT'S SECOND BEST.
AND HAD ALEXANDRIA
NOT BEEN SO FRICKIN' ANNOYING,
WE PROBABLY WOULD'VE WON.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO GOOD JOB TODAY,
AND I'LL SEE YOU GUYS REAL SOON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
>> I WAS TOTALLY TELLING MYSELF
"ACTION," NOT YOU.
I WASN'T LOOKING LIKE,
'OKAY, YO, ACTION."
>> I HOPE MR. JAY SAYS SOMETHING
ABOUT HOW SHE ACTED
AT CHALLENGE TODAY.
JUST SEND THE GIRL
WITH THE BAD ATTITUDE HOME.
I DON'T CARE
HOW GOOD HER PICTURES ARE.
NO ONE IN THE INDUSTRY IS
GONNA WANT TO WORK WITH HER.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW GET READY
TO TAKE A WALK
ON THE WILD SIDE."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> YAY!
>> I CAN'T WAIT!
>> WILD ANIMALS!
>> "TAKE A WALK ON THE WILD"...
>> WE'RE GONNA BE WALKING
WITH TIGERS.
>> IT'S GONNA BE
A MOVEMENT SHOOT.
>> MY TEAM DID NOT WIN
THE CHALLENGE,
AND I'M NOT GONNA BLAME IT
ON ANYBODY BUT MYSELF.
BUT I'M NOT PANICKING.
I'M JUST TRYING TO STAY
AS CALM AS POSSIBLE,
BECAUSE IF I TRY TO, YOU KNOW,
GET ALL ANTSY AND STUFF,
THAT'S JUST GONNA
MAKE THINGS WORSE.
(phone rings)
>> Hello?
>> HEY.
>> Hey. How are you?
>> IT'S, LIKE, I'M ALREADY
BEING, LIKE,
LOOKED AT DIFFERENTLY AND STUFF,
AND I REALLY DON'T LIKE IT.
>> I mean,
you just gotta stay strong.
I love you to death.
No matter what happens,
it doesn't matter.
>> MY MOM AND DAD SPLIT UP
BECAUSE OF ABUSE,
AND I HAVE ALWAYS
REALLY FELT THE NEED
TO PROTECT MY SIBLINGS.
SO I... HAD TO GROW UP FAST
AND BECOME VERY WISE
BEYOND MY YEARS.
(crying) AND I FEEL
THAT IF THE GIRLS IN THE HOUSE
UNDERSTOOD,
MAYBE THEY'D UNDERSTAND
THAT I WAS JUST ONLY TRYING
TO FIX AND HELP
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO MY WHOLE LIFE.
>> How's your competition
and stuff?
I mean, everyone cool? Is it...
>> UM...
YEAH.
>> DOES SHE TAKE
ANY MEDICATION? JUST CURIOUS.
>> SHE SHOULD.
>> I WONDER HOW SHE FEELS
ABOUT ALL OF US, HONESTLY.
>> THAT WOULD BE--
>> SHOULD WE LOOK IN HER DIARY
RIGHT NOW?
>> NO! THAT'S--THAT'S DIRTY.
>> I... MIGHT'VE HAD THE IDEA
THAT, WELL,
LET'S LOOK IN HER DIARY,
ONLY TO SEE IF--
HOW SHE WAS REALLY FEELING
ABOUT US.
>> UM, IF HERE GONNA DO IT,
YOU BETTER (bleep)
HURRY YOUR AS UP.
>> YEAH.
>> GO, DUDE!
>> ARE YOU IN THIS?
>> I'M SORRY.
WE HAVE TO KNOW
IF SHE LIKES US OR NOT.
>> (laughs)
>> OH!
OH, MY GOD. IT'S BAD! IT'S BAD!
>> OH, MY LORD.
MY HEART JUST DROPPED.
THIS IS GONNA BE TERRIBLE.
>> (speaks inaudibly)
>> OH, MY GOD!
IT'S BAD! IT'S BAD!
>> WE WERE ALL SITTING
IN THE LIVING ROOM AREA,
MINUS ALEXANDRIA,
AND MONIQUE IS READING
LEX'S DIARY.
>> SHE SAYS THIS--
"I DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW TO FEEL RIGHT NOW. LONER."
SAD SMILEY.
>> THIS IS TERRIBLE.
>> SHE DOESN'T KNOW
HOW SHE COMES OFF TO US,
AND SHE IS, LIKE...
>> THAT'S, LIKE, WORSE.
>> SHE'S LIKE,
"WHY AM I A LONER?"
IT'S, LIKE, WHY ARE YOU
BEING SUCH A CRAZY BITCH?
>> IT'S SO CONFUSING TO ME.
>> WE JUST NEEDED TO KNOW
IF SHE, LIKE, WAS SECRETLY
TALKING (bleep) ABOUT US...
>> YEAH, AND SHE WASN'T.
>> AND NOW SHE FEELS...
I FEEL REALLY BAD,
LIKE, SHOULD I TELL HER
THAT, LIKE,
I LOOKED IN HER DIARY?
NO?
>> I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'LL BE A GOOD IDEA.
>> (laughs)
(elephant trumpets)
>> WE GET A TYRA MAIL THAT SAID
"A WALK ON THE WILD SIDE."
WE THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING IN MOTION,
BUT WHETHER IT'S WITH ANIMALS
OR WHETHER IT'S
SOME KIND OF CRAZY, LIKE, STUNT,
I THINK WE'RE
JUST REALLY EXCITED
TO DO SOMETHING WILD.
(hawk cries)
>> HELLO!
>> OH, HI!
>> HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
>> GOOD.
>> ISN'T THIS COOL?
WE'RE IN THE OLD L.A. ZOO.
THIS IS THE PERFECT SETTING
TO LET YOUR INNER WILD SIDE
COME OUT
AS YOU GUYS ARE TRANSFORMED
INTO FASHION VERSIONS
OF ANIMALS.
>> YAY!
>> AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY IS
BALDOMERO FERNANDEZ,
AND HE SHOT FOR "W"
AND "VANITY FAIR."
HE'S A REALLY AMAZING GUY,
KIND OF ZEN ENERGY.
I LOVE IT. SO, BALDOMERO.
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> HI.
>> TODAY, I WANT YOU GUYS
TO JUST TAKE IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND LET YOUR WILD SIDE COME OUT.
>> SO WARDROBE-WISE,
YOU GUYS ARE ACTUALLY GONNA
BE WEARING PIECES
FROM RACHEL ZOE'S
FAUX FUR COLLECTION.
SHE'S GONNA BE YOUR GUEST JUDGE
AT THE NEXT JUDGING.
>> YES!
>> AHH! I'M JUST SO EXCITED.
I GET TO MEET
FREAKIN' RACHEL ZOE.
I'M JUST SO, SO GLAD
IT'S FAUX FUR.
>> SO WHY DON'T YOU GUYS HEAD
OVER HERE TO THE VERDE TRAILER
FOR HAIR AND MAKEUP,
AND WE'LL GET YOU GUYS
ALL GLAMMED UP?
>> HI.
>> HI, GUYS.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> GOOD.
>> WE'RE GONNA BE WILD THINGS.
>> I'M EXCITED.
>> SO WE'RE USING THESE TAPES
TO TAPE UP YOUR EYES.
IT'S PRETTY MUCH
WHAT THE DRAG QUEENS DO.
>> IS THAT RIGHT? (chuckles)
ALL RIGHT.
>> GIVE YOU EXPRESSION
IN YOUR FACE.
>> IT'S NATURALLY
NOT THIS CURLY.
THIS IS--LIKE,
THAT'S ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE.
MM, IT'S FRUSTRATING, THIS HAIR.
SO IT'S NOT GONNA BE
TOO MUCH WORK FOR Y'ALL?
IT'S A PAIN IN MY ASS,
BUT, UM, YOU KNOW,
I'M GONNA DEAL WITH IT,
OBVIOUSLY,
'CAUSE I WANT THIS REALLY BADLY.
(jaguar growls)
>> MURATO, THERE'S LOTS
OF LITTLE GIRLS HERE.
>> OH, MY GOD! I'M GONNA CRY.
>> YEAH, LOOK, GUYS.
I GOT A LITTLE BABY JAGUAR.
>> OH!
>> LOOK. MURATO IS GOING TO BE
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
WITH YOU GUYS.
>> YAY!
WE LITERALLY GET
TO POSE WITH AN ANIMAL,
AND THAT'S WHEN MY SMILE
GETS FROM EAR TO EAR.
>> IF HE TURNS
TOWARDS YOUR FACE,
YOU'RE GONNA WANNA FACE HIM OUT,
BECAUSE HIS NATURAL INSTINCT
IS TO GRAB ON
WITH HIS LITTLE TEETH.
>> WITH HIS MOUTH.
>> OKAY?
>> (growls)
>> UH-OH.
>> OH, GREAT.
>> (growling)
>> AW!
>> I'M NOT REALLY A CAT PERSON.
LIKE, I HATE CATS, IN GENERAL.
>> HE IS THE CUTEST THING
I'VE EVER SEEN.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HE'S GONNA TRY HIS BEST
TO DISTRACT YOU.
>> OH.
>> (growls)
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> I WAS, LIKE, THE MAMA JAGUAR,
AND MURATO WAS MY BABY.
I WAS JUST HOLDING HIM
AND LETTING HIM,
LIKE, SLINK AROUND.
>> UP. UP WITH YOUR EYES. YEAH.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> THE SHOTS ARE AMAZING.
THIS IS KINDA, LIKE,
A GREAT RECOVERY, COMING OUT
OF THE CHALLENGE THIS WEEK...
>> YEAH, I REALLY THINK IT IS.
>> WHICH I THINK
YOUR PROBABLY LEARNED A LOT.
I MEAN, IT WAS
JUST RIGHT IN THE ZONE.
>> LOOK IN THE CAMERA. OKAY.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> IT'S GORGEOUS.
>> COME BACK.
>> OOH, THAT'S REALLY SEXY.
START MODELING NOW, MIKAELA,
'CAUSE HE COULD BE SHOOTING.
>> OKAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE JUST
SITTING THERE, STROKING HIM...
>> OKAY.
>> AND YOU'RE NOT REALLY
MODELING THROUGH THIS.
>> MM.
>> (growls)
>> SORRY.
NO. I'M SORRY.
AM I DOING SOMETHING WRONG?
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PETS
OR ANIMALS?
OH, YEAH, I CAN TELL.
>> IT'S OBVIOUS.
>> YOU'RE SO AWKWARD.
>> (groans)
I'M ALLERGIC TO EVERYTHING.
I NEVER HAD A PET.
I THOUGHT I HAD
SOME POSES WORKED OUT,
BUT, UM, WHAT MESSED
WITH MY HEAD WAS HAVING THE CAT
AND, LIKE, NOT BEING COMFORTABLE
WITH IT.
OOH! (bleep) I'M SORRY.
>> SO WHAT WOULD YOU DO
RIGHT NOW IF YOU DIDN'T EVEN
HAVE TO HOLD HIM?
DO YOU THINK
THAT LOOKS FLATTERING?
I DON'T THINK IT HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH MURATO.
I DON'T THINK KASIA KNEW
HOW TO KIND OF FEATURE
THIS REALLY COOL
RACHEL ZOE FAUX FUR VEST.
AND THEN HER PHOTOS
JUST WENT DOWNHILL FAST.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH! YAY!
>> STUPID BITCH.
(groans)
>> DON'T WORRY.
SHE'LL BE GONE SOON.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S TRUE.
PROBABLY NOT
BECAUSE WE WANT IT SO BAD.
>> HEY! NO TOUCH.
>> OH. SORRY.
>> IT'S SETTING.
PLEASE DON'T TOUCH.
>> I WON'T TOUCH IT.
>> IT WAS VERY NEAT
BECAUSE I REALLY WAS
LOOKING FORWARD
TO LOOKING LIKE A LION,
AND SO I'M--I'M VERY EXCITED
TO WEAR RACHEL ZOE'S FAUX FURS.
OH, COME HERE, BIG BOY.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> JACLYN, I LOVE HOW YOU'RE
ALMOST KIND OF TAKING ON
THIS FELINE QUALITY.
LIKE, I'M ALMOST GETTING
"LIONESS" OUT OF YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> (growls)
>> THAT'S GORGEOUS. HOLD THAT.
>> GOOD. NICE. NICE.
>> TODAY, EVERYTHING DALYA DID
WAS REMEDIAL MODELING.
"LET ME PUT MY HAND ON MY HEAD.
LET ME PUT MY HAND ON MY HIP.
LET ME CROSS MY LEGS."
I DIDN'T KNOW
WHO THIS PERSON WAS.
IT'S, LIKE, YOU WENT RIGHT BACK
TO THE MOST COMMON, KIND OF,
LIKE, MODEL 101...
>> POSE.
>> AND YOU'RE JUST
TRYING TO PLEASE.
IT WAS JUST A STRUGGLE.
I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
IT WAS A STRUGGLE TODAY.
>> OKAY, THANK YOU.
(crying) I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK I JUST GOT LOST
OUT THERE.
AND I WASN'T TRYING TO GET LOST,
BUT IT KINDA HURTS
BECAUSE I WANT THIS
MORE THAN ANYBODY HERE.
I KNOW HOW TO--
I KNOW HOW TO MODEL.
I PROVED THAT.
>> THE CAT'S REALLY TIRED...
>> YEAH.
>> SO IT'S REALLY GONNA
HAVE TO BE ALL ABOUT YOU.
>> "IT'S THE LITTLE JAGUAR'S
BEDTIME NOW."
I'M LIKE, PERFECT.
>> THAT'S NICE.
>> YOU KNOW,
I DON'T REALLY LIKE CATS,
BUT IT WAS COOL
TO HOLD A BABY JAGUAR,
AND I WAS COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
>> THIS IS REALLY GOOD, MONIQUE.
I REALLY LOVE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
>> WHEN SHE WALKED ONTO SET,
I WAS A LITTLE WORRIED.
MONIQUE WAS, LIKE, KINDA STIFF,
BUT SHE REALLY TURNED IT ON
AS SOON AS I PUT THE CAMERA
UP TO MY FACE.
SHE WORKED GREAT
WITH THE CAT AS WELL.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> I'M NOT SURE
IF THE CAT'S MAKING YOU NERVOUS
OR WHAT, BUT YOU'RE--
YOU'RE LOOKING LIKE
YOU'RE LIKE THIS...
>> I WAS, LIKE, SECOND TO LAST,
LIKE I ALWAYS AM,
AND THE JAGUAR
STARTED GETTING REALLY CRANKY.
SO, YEAH,
I KEEP GETTING (bleep).
WHAT IS HE DOING?
>> INSTEAD OF IT BEING
LIKE AN INTIMATE MOMENT,
I REALLY NEED TO FEEL
A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF THAT ANIMALISTIC PASSION.
>> OKAY.
>> MOLLY WAS VERY JARRING
TO LOOK AT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T AT ALL
WHAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR.
IF YOU LOOK AT YOURSELF
IN THE MIRROR,
AND YOU'RE MADE
TO LOOK LIKE THIS LIONESS,
WHY WOULD YOU TRY
AND BE LIKE JUNE CLEAVER?
(hums)
IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> LOOK TO ME.
>> REMEMBER, ALEXANDRIA,
HE'S NOT YOUR LOVER
OR YOUR BABY.
I KNOW YOU WANT TO CUDDLE HIM.
>> YES, SIR.
>> (growls)
>> ALEXANDRIA'S JUST A BRAT,
BUT THEN THE SECOND
SHE GETS IN FRONT OF JAY,
SHE TRIES TO PRETEND TO BE NICE
JUST SO HE'LL GIVE GOOD FEEDBACK
SO SHE WON'T GO HOME.
>> BE CAREFUL
WITH THE BODY LANGUAGE
SO IT DOESN'T GET TOO HOOCHIE.
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S REALLY HARD
TO JUGGLE EVERYBODY AROUND
AND THE CAT,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
TRYING TO DELIVER
A PERFECT PICTURE.
>> (growls)
>> (barks)
(barks)
>> THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD BARK.
>> ALEXANDRIA STARTED BARKING.
SHE'S CRAZY, DUDE.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
>> (hisses)
>> OH, THAT'S GREAT.
THAT'S GREAT.
>> (hisses)
>> OKAY. COOL, BALDOMERO.
THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYBODY.
GOOD JOB.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHEN YOU HAVE
MR. JAY COMING AT YOU,
SAYING "THIS IS MODELING 101"--
THAT HURTS TO HEAR THAT,
BUT I CHANGED THAT AROUND
WHEN HE SAID THAT.
>> RIGHT. YOU DID FIX IT.
>> I WORKED OUT
TO A DIFFERENT POSE.
AND TODAY WAS ONE OF THOSE DAYS
WHERE HE JUST SAID
HE JUST DIDN'T LIKE IT.
I NEED TO TAKE
WHAT MR. JAY SAYS,
TURN IT AROUND FOR NEXT WEEK,
'CAUSE HONESTLY,
HE'S TALKING TO ME BECAUSE
HE KNOWS I CAN DO BETTER.
>> DID MR. JAY, UH, TALK TO YOU
AFTER YOUR THING?
>> UM, I DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
IT WAS KIND OF, LIKE,
THEY WERE WANTINGTO HEAR
SOMETHING BAD MAYBE,
BECAUSE I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
BECAUSE OF MY ATTITUDE.
BUT I HAVE
A REALLY GOOD ATTITUDE,
AND I THINK JAY SAW THAT,
SO HOPEFULLY
THAT'S SPOKEN ABOUT AT PANEL.
I HAVE ONE LAST CHANCE.
>> I CAN'T EVEN PUT IT UP.
LIKE, IT WON'T EVEN STAY.
I THINK SOME PEOPLE GOT IT
MUCH EASIER THAN WE DID
AT THE VERY END.
I'M DEFINITELY FEELING
A LITTLE BEATEN DOWN
FROM MY HAIRSTYLE,
BUT I'M PRETTY SURE
THAT I GOT SOME GOOD SHOTS.
>> I LIKE IT. I LIKE IT.
>> WHATEVER.
AT LEAST IT'S OUT OF THE WAY.
REALLY, IF ALEXANDRIA LEFT,
WE'D ALL BE FINE.
IF SOMEONE THAT--THAT DESERVES
TO BE HERE GOES HOME
AND SHE DOESN'T,
I'M GONNA BE REALLY UPSET.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IS THAT FROM "A" TO THE ZOE
IN THE HOUSE?
>> HI, LADY.
>> AW!
>> I GOT A LITTLE DRESSED UP
FOR YOU.
>> FANTASTIC.
>> A LITTLE GLAM FOR YOU.
>> MWAH.
>> YOU ALWAYS SMELL SO GOOD.
>> DO I?
>> YEAH.
>> IT'S CALLED "OIL de ANDRÉ."
>> OH, IT'S LIKE
"SMELL GOOD FROM THE SHOWER."
(laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> HOW WE DOIN'?
>> GOOD.
>> YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES--
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS,
A CONTRACT WITH IMG MODELS,
ONE OF THE TOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA,"
AND YOU'LL GET A COVER
OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
LIKE OUR CYCLE 15 WINNER ANN.
OUR JUDGES--
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY, ONE OF
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND OUR GUEST JUDGE RACHEL ZOE.
NOW LET ME TELL YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT STYLISTS.
IT USED TO BE STYLISTS
WERE IN THE BACKGROUND,
DESIGNERS HAD ALL THE POWER.
NOW STYLISTS DETERMINE
WHO THE NEXT TOP MODELS
ARE GOING TO BE,
WHO THE NEXT CELEBRITIES
ARE GOING TO BE.
SO THIS LADY IS
A LADY TO PLEASE.
ARE WE READY TO START
THIS JUDGING?
>> YES.
>> LET'S GO.
AND, JUDGES, THE LADIES
DID THEIR PHOTO SHOOT
AT THE OLD L.A. ZOO,
AND OUR LOVELY MODELS
WERE WEARING RACHEL ZOE'S
NEW FAUX FUR LINE.
AND THE FIRST GIRL--JACLYN.
>> HELLO.
>> YOU WERE MODELING AT THE ZOO
WITH A BABY JAGUAR.
>> YES. HE WAS SO CUTE.
>> HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> STUNNING.
>> I THINK THAT THERE'S, UM,
STRENGTH IN THE PHOTO.
I'M FEELING
A WHOLE '80s VIBE HERE.
>> THE BIG HAIR AND THE LIGHT.
>> WITH THE BIG HAIR, DISCO.
>> TOTALLY. TOTALLY.
I'M LOOKING AT THIS,
AND I WOULD NEVER THINK
THAT THIS VOICE
COMES FROM THIS PHOTO.
IT'S SO STRONG.
>> I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT YOUR LEFT ARM
UNDERNEATH RACHEL'S FUR
WITH THAT LOOK ON YOUR FACE.
IT LOOKS A LITTLE FREAKY-DEAKY.
YOU KNOW, I PROBABLY
WOULD'VE LIKED TO SEE THAT HAND
A LITTLE MORE EXPOSED.
>> (laughs)
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT UP--MIKAELA.
>> MIKAELA GOT SOME NEW SHOES.
>> YEAH, SHE DOES.
>> THOSE ARE--
THOSE ARE KIND OF AMAZING.
>> AMAZING.
>> I LOVE THEM.
>> I THINK
THEY'RE AMAZING, TOO.
>> ALL RIGHT,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> VERY FLAT.
I THINK THE HAND IS WEAK
OVER HERE.
THE HAND SHOULD EVOKE POWER.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THIS SHOT,
IS THAT I GO STRAIGHT TO YOU.
YOU'RE SEDUCING THE VIEWER.
>> I WENT THROUGH YOUR FILM,
AND WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO
IS PUT TENSION IN YOUR BODY.
EVERY NOW AND THEN,
YOU DID THAT THING
THAT I TOLD YOU TO DO...
AND THEN IT GOES... (sighs)
IT'S, LIKE, IT COMES
AND IT GOES.
YOU NEED TO GRAB ON
TO THE HANDLEBARS OF FIERCENESS
AND NOT LET GO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT--MOLLY.
OOH, MOLLY!
IF YOU SURVIVE THIS WEEK,
I AM YANKING THAT WEAVE OUT.
IT'S JUST NOT WORKING.
>> PLEASE.
>> OKAY, HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOUR FACE IS INTERESTING.
THERE'S DEFINITELY A LOOK THERE.
THERE'S A PASSION,
BUT YOU MISS THE FASHION
ALTOGETHER.
I DON'T REALLY GET IT.
>> AND YOUR HAND HERE IS
ACTUALLY BIGGER THAN YOUR FACE.
THAT'S NOT PRETTY IN ANY PHOTO.
>> MOLLY, I FELT YOU WERE
ASLEEP IN YOUR FILM,
JUST, LIKE, NOT PRESENT.
AND IF IT'S BECAUSE
OF A BAD WEAVE, HONEY,
I'M THE QUEEN OF THE BAD WEAVES,
BUT I MADE SURE THAT THIS
I HAD CONTROL OVER.
OKAY? THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
>> UP NEXT IS MONIQUE.
YOU LOOK NICE AND CLEAN
AND CHIC.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU PULLED IT OFF,
BUT I THINK THAT YOU LUCKED UP
WITH THE CAT DOING
THE BIG, OPEN YAWN/ROAR.
>> I THINK IT LOOKS
ABSOLUTELY FABULOUS,
AND YOU'RE NOT--BEING UPSTAGED
BY TONY THE JAGUAR.
>> THE TIGER. (laughs)
>> TONY THE JAGUAR.
>> TONY THE TIGER
TONY THE JAGUAR.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> KASIA, WHO WAS
PART OF THE GROUP CHALLENGE WIN,
AS WELL AS MIKAELA.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO LET'S SEE
IF YOUR PHOTO IS ANIMALISTIC.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF '80s
GOING ON WITH THE HAIR
AND THE MAKEUP AND THE LOOK
AND THE ZONE.
>> WHEN YOU DO FAUX FUR,
YOU THINK OF THAT, YOU KNOW,
CRAZY, KIND OF ANIMAL,
VERY '80s, YOU KNOW,
THAT--THAT WHOLE THING.
>> "DYNASTY" GIRL.
>> TOTALLY.
UM, BUT IT REALLY WORKED.
>> AND WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THIS PHOTO IS
I SEE A FIERCELY REAL GIRL
THAT IS GIVING
EDITORIAL ENERGY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS SAYS TO ME.
MR. JAY SAID THAT YOU WERE
"THE MOST UNCOORDINATED
AND TENTATIVE OF THE DAY."
I AGREE. YOU LUCKED OUT ON THIS.
"YOU SEEMED LIKE
A FISH OUT OF WATER
AND YOU WERE NOT PRESENT."
WHAT WAS THE SITUATION HERE
THAT MADE YOU FALL APART.
>> I'VE NEVER HAD PETS.
I'M ALLERGIC TO EVERYTHING,
SO IT'S, LIKE, REALLY DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO EVEN HOLD HIM.
>> WELL, THIS WAS ONE OF THOSE
WHERE IT'S, LIKE,
A LUCK SHOT OUT OF A LOT.
>> YEAH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT--DALYA.
>> HELLO.
>> DALYA, YOU LOOK CHIC
FROM WEEK TO WEEK.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> ARE WE READY
TO SEE YOUR PICTURE?
>> YES, I AM.
>> WHEN I-I LOOK AT THIS SHOT,
I ALMOST SEE TEARS IN YOUR EYES.
I MEAN, IT'S--IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE--YOU WERE TAKEN
TO A POINT WHERE YOU WERE
SLIGHTLY DESPERATE.
"IS THIS GONNA WORK?"
>> I THINK YOU COULD'VE
BEEN THE ONE LADY
WHO COULD'VE
JUST BEEN EXTRAORDINARY,
IF YOU JUST OPENED YOUR MOUTH
AND ROAREDOR SOMETHING.
>> I DID NOT KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THAT ANIMAL.
I WANTED TO REALLY GIVE YOU GUYS
A POWERFUL PICTURE.
>> BUT IT'S NOT GIVING IT TO US,
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> MM-HMM.
>> YOU HAVE TO GIVE IT
TO YOURSELF.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE ADVICE I GIVE TO YOU--
WHEN YOU MODEL,
BECAUSE OF YOUR BONE STRUCTURE,
YOU CAN'T JUST STAND THERE,
BECAUSE YOUR BONE STRUCTURE
WEARS YOU. OKAY, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BRITTANI--
ANOTHER CHALLENGE WINNER.
>> I'M LOOKING AT THIS.
I'M LIKE, WHO ARE YOU STANDING
IN FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW?
>> SHE IS A FABULOUS,
FABULOUS WOMAN
IN CONTROL OF HER DESTINY
WITH HER PET JAGUAR.
YOU LOOK LIKE A CONTESSA.
>> RACHEL, I WANT THIS COAT.
>> YEAH, UH,
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
>> YEAH, LIKE,
LITERALLY, I WANT.
CAN YOU, LIKE, SEND IT TO ME?
>> LITERALLY,
YOU WILL HAVE THAT.
>> A MODEL'S JOB IS
TO SELL SOMETHING...
>> YES.
>> AND RIGHT NOW,
ALL OF US WANT THIS JACKET,
INCLUDING ME.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT--ALEXANDRIA.
>> OOH!
>> IF I TOOK THE ANIMAL AWAY,
I DON'T THINK YOU LOOK GENIUS
IN THIS SHOT.
>> NO.
>> AND I THINK
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
IT'S THAT YOU'RE NOT EMOTING.
IT'S THE FACT THAT THE ANIMAL
HAS GOT SO MUCH CHARACTER
THAT IT'S COME ALIVE.
>> I DO LOVE
WHAT YOU'RE GIVING TO IT.
I'M NOT SURE THAT...
>> YEAH.
>> THE OTHER HAND IS GIVING
EVEN NEAR THAT,
'CAUSE IT JUST TAKES, YOU KNOW,
ONE AWKWARD,
KIND OF ARM SITUATION
TO RUIN THE PHOTO.
>> YES. YEAH, I THINK IT'S FUN.
I DON'T THINK
IT'S VERY MODELESQUE.
>> NO.
>> I DON'T THINK
IT'S HIGH FASHION.
>> NO.
>> BUT WHEN YOU DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
KEEP ON DOING IT.
THERE'S ONLY ONE FRAME OF THIS.
>> OKAY. YES.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> HANNAH, COME ON UP.
>> A GAZE--OOH! LOOK AT...
>> WHOA.
>> THE WHOLE THING IS SO LUSH.
I LOVE WHEN THE ANIMAL FEELS
SO RELAXED IN THE ARMS.
>> THIS IS WOW, IS WHAT THIS IS.
I CAN'T GET OVER YOU RIGHT NOW.
WHERE IS THE FAUX FUR?
I MEAN,
AND--AND I'M THE DESIGNER HERE,
AND I DON'T ACTUALLY CARE
IF I SEE IT BECAUSE I'M SO...
>> (laughs)
>> I'M SO INTRIGUED.
>> I LIKE THAT YOU CAN DO
A SOFT COMMERCIAL
AND THEN YOU CAN BE
A HIGH FASHION GIRL
THAT'S TURNING INTO A JAMAICAN.
(imitates Jamaican accent)
MY ACCENT'S TURNED HERE.
YEAH, I DON'T KNOW WHY.
(normal voice) THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH GIRL
IS... EXTINCT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IT'S TIME TO DELIBERATE.
SOMEBODY'S GOING HOME.
SO JACLYN.
>> I THINK SHE JUST MADE IT
LOOK EXTRAORDINARY AND SEXY.
>> THIS PICTURE WORKS FOR ME.
IT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE BEST.
IT'S GOT SOME REAL ATTITUDE
TO IT.
>> THIS IS
AN INCREDIBLY POWERFUL PHOTO
OVERALL.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> IF THE CAT HADN'T DONE THIS,
THIS WOULDN'T BE INTERESTING
AT ALL.
>> IT'S--IT'S NOT MY FAVORITE.
I WOULDN'T HANG IT ANYWHERE.
>> THE ONE THING--
WHEN A MODEL MAKES
THE UGLY/PRETTY FACE,
YOU WANT IT TO BE
EDITORIAL AND FASHION,
AND THIS IS JUST
AN UGLY/PRETTY FACE.
MIKAELA.
>> I HAVEN'T BEEN WOWED
BY MIKAELA, BUT IN THIS SHOT,
IT'S ALL ABOUT HER EYES.
IT'S JUST FOR THAT MOMENT...
(growls)
>> (growls) MIKAELA'S
ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
WHERE I WISH I WAS ON THE SET
AND I CAN GO, "LISTEN TO ME!"
>> (laughs)
>> "YOU HAVE SO MUCH POTENTIAL!"
MOLLY.
>> WELL, IF THIS IS
HER BEST PHOTO,
THAT'S PROBLEMATIC.
>> NOW WHICH PART OF THAT
WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC?
THE CROSSED EYE, THE BIG HAND,
THE FACT THAT YOU DON'T SEE
YOUR COAT, OR THE FACT
THAT SHE HAS HER SISTER'S HAIR?
>> DON'T FAULT HER FOR THE HAIR.
>> IT'S NOT JUST THE HAIR.
SHE'S LOST THE COAT.
>> MONIQUE.
>> OH, MONIQUE WAS
"THE VAMPIRE DIARIES,"
SO I LOVED HER.
SHE'S LOOKING FOR
THE NEXT VICTIM
IN THE UNDERGROUND.
>> I LOVE, OBVIOUSLY,
WHAT THE ANIMAL IS DOING,
BUT I ALSO LOVE THAT THERE'S
A CONFIDENCE SHE HAS THERE.
>> DALYA.
>> THIS ISN'T FASHION.
I MEAN, SHE'S JUST NOT
TAKING ANY RISKS.
>> I THINK A GIRL
WITH BONE STRUCTURE LIKE DALYA
NEEDS TO MOVE AROUND THAT SET
LIKE A BUNNY...
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND CREATE ANGLES
AND INTERESTING SHAPES...
>> MM-HMM.
>> OR ELSE HER FACE IS
WEARING HER.
HANNAH.
>> THIS SHOT OF HANNAH IS
JUST EXTRAORDINARY.
>> THERE ARE CERTAIN PICTURES
IN MAGAZINES,
WHERE YOU LOOK
FOR THAT DAMN CAPTION AND GO,
"OH, WHAT IS THIS?
WHAT ARE THESE CLOTHES?
OKAY, I'M GONNA BUY
WHATEVER SHE HAS ON."
>> IT'S AN ICONIC PHOTOGRAPH,
THIS ONE, FOR SURE.
>> YEAH. KASIA.
>> CAVE MAMA.
I THINK KASIA IS FANTASTIC.
I THINK IT WORKS.
>> WHEN I SAW HER
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
I THOUGHT, OKAY, SHE'S GONNA GO
A LITTLE BIT INEXPENSIVE.
>> OH!
>> INTERESTING.
YOU MEAN "CHEAP."
>> YEAH.
BUT I--BUT I HAVE TO SAY,
I LOOK AT THIS PHOTO
AND I SEE
CROSSOVER TO EDITORIAL.
>> BRITTANI.
>> BRITTANI ABSOLUTELY
DOES NOT LOOK INEXPENSIVE.
>> NO, SHE DOES NOT.
SHE LOOKS SO RICH TO ME.
>> I WOULD LOOK AT THIS COAT
AND THINK,
"I CAN'T AFFORD THIS COAT."
>> BUT YOU CAN, BLANCHE.
>> YOU CAN. YOU CAN.
>> YOU CAN. IT'S FAUX FUR.
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> NINE BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE EIGHT PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE EIGHT OF YOU THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BEST PICTURE OF THE WEEK
GOES TO...
HANNAH.
WHOO-HOO, LADY.
(laughs) CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> RUNNER-UP FOR BEST PHOTO...
BRITTANI.
>> (mouths words)
>> JACLYN.
>> (sighs)
>> QUEEN OF THE NIGHT,
VAMPIRE MONIQUE.
ALEXANDRIA.
(growls)
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
KASIA.
MIKAELA.
>> (sighs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS, MIKAELA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
MOLLY AND DALYA,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
TWO BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR HOUSE HERE
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES,
PACK YOUR BAGS, AND GO HOME.
MOLLY, YOU'VE HAD HAIR TROUBLE
IN THIS COMPETITION.
NOW I WOULD USUALLY SAY,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
BUT THE HAIR WAS SO BAD
THIS WEEK.
LET'S GIVE HER A CHANCE."
BUT YOU HAD A BAD HAIR WEAVE
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO,
AND YOU HAD ONE OF
THE BEST PICTURES IN THE BUNCH.
YOUR FILM THIS WEEK
WAS DISENGAGED.
YOU WERE VACANT.
THE MOLLY THAT I CHOSE
WEEKS AND WEEKS AND WEEKS AGO--
SHE WASN'T THERE.
AND THEN WE HAVE DALYA--
THIS GORGEOUS BONE STRUCTURE,
STUNNING GIRL
WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE EXPERIENCE
THAN A COUPLE OF GIRLS HERE,
BUT IT SEEMS
YOU WANT THIS SO MUCH,
AND THERE'S SUCH A DESPERATION
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
THAT MAYBE YOU STAND
IN YOUR OWN WAY.
BOTH OF YOU LEAVE THE JUDGES
PERPLEXED.
SO WHO STAYS?
>> MOLLY.
>> DON'T FALL APART, MOLLY.
I'M GONNA START BY
TAKING THAT THING OFF YOUR HAIR.
AND YOU'RE GONNA WORK
WITH WHAT MAMA AND DADDY MADE.
>> (chuckles)
>> OKAY?
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE PICTURES ARE
GONNA GET ANY BETTER
BECAUSE OF THAT.
IT HAS TO COME
FROM INSIDE OF YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> (crying)
>> YOU HAVE SO MUCH EXPERIENCE
ALREADY.
>> I--
>> YOU'VE WALKED, LIKE,
FASHION WEEK IN L.A. AND STUFF.
>> I KNOW.
>> THESE GIRLS
HAVEN'T DONE THAT.
BUT THE STRENGTH HAS TO COME
FROM INSIDE,
'CAUSE YOU KNOW
THE REAL WORLD OF MODELING IS
EVEN CRAZIER THAN "TOP MODEL."
>> IT IS. MM-HMM. (sniffles)
>> RIGHT? OKAY. GIVE ME A HUG.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
THIS PARTICULAR SHOOT
WAS THE REASON WHY I WENT HOME.
THIS TIME I WAS
THINKING WAY TOO MUCH,
AND DOUBTING MYSELF AS WELL.
IT'S THE WORST FEELING,
KNOWING THAT YOU WON'T BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE ON
AND SHOW THAT YOU HAVE
SO MUCH MORE TO GIVE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I LET MYSELF GET IN MY WAY,
AND I'M ALMOST EMBARRASSED,
BUT I'M STILL PROUD OF MYSELF.
I STILL MADE IT TO THE TOP NINE.
BYE.
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.